now once you stop them in the first
fight the second fight is the fight
that's probably the most famous fight
because he bit a chunk of your ear off
and I saw it when you're coming in here
show everybody that did you ever think
about getting that fixed no no that's my
identification I got my ID I just showed
but yeah that is right if you want to
get into somewhere of Do You Know Who I
am look at my hair yeah yeah that's
crazy man that was one of the craziest
moments when Mills Lane looked at you
and you were jumping up in the air and
looked at Tyson and realized holy [ __ ]
he bit a chunk out of your [ __ ] ear
right like what what were you thinking
at that time fighting back I'm serious I
was getting ready to bite the daylights
out of him and I'm gonna bite him in the
face I would bite his face I wouldn't
wait for the ear I'm gonna get the fat
sup you know come you know where are you
from - ghetto they say if you do
something you got to do it worse than
what they did right and so you know and
I told my and talk show I said no I said
no I I won't pretend it like and like I
was hurting real bad ice but I'm gonna
trip you up the place you read in your
face
everybody know what I was gonna do ice
button yeah this this prophet told us
before the fight he told me he said look
he gonna do something in your face area
but you got to stay focused cause if you
don't stay focused god that's the only
way he gonna get you
so by him by him in my ear when a man
and I knew I'll get me to buy him back
and and but my corner person started
telling me keep my mind on the Lord hmm
and because the Prophet told me say only
way he can get you to get your mind he
he gonna do something to you right I
thought he gonna hit me way elbow hit
button anything like that button I never
ever thought in my life he would bite
Malia and fight a chunkier halt and it
hurt so bad people some how bad did it
hurt
did you see how high jump
oh no it was crazy just leaped up in the
air yeah it hurt so bad and I said Dan I
said then that guy my corner guy Tim
hallmark we kept telling me to keep my
mind on the Lord and I ain't wanna hear
that you know even though he was Santa
and I was man I was still I was just
trying to remember that get him I want
to bite him I really wanted to bite him
back and and all of a sudden I hit my
mind dad they always catch the second
person right I'm telling anything in
life and I'm the one that people only
did some too they will always catch me
and I'm the only one to get get cold all
the time cuz they always catch me trying
to get to get back so revenge is the
Lord so you don't go get back cause you
gonna get cold
yeah